et xavier bertrand l'une des figures de
l'ump qui se projette en 2017 est avec
nous bonsoir et merci d'être là et
invité de preuves par 3 vous inaugurez
notre nouveau studio xavier bertrand ce
rendez-vous réalisé en partenariat avec
l' agence france presse qui sera
représenté dans quelques instants sur ce
plateau par suzette bloch en partenariat
également avec dailymotion alors avant
d'évoquer votre stratégie personnelle
gens disaient un mot xavier bertrand à
la fin de cette émission avec perrine
tarneaud voyons quel angle d'attaqué
vous privilégiez contre le gouvernement
on peut parler d'abord du déficit de la
branche famille de la sécurité sociale
un déficit qui a explosé sous le
précédent quinquennat c'est l'argument
que met en avant le gouvernement pour
avancer des réformes avec l'idée donc de
parlementaires socialistes de réduire
les prestations par les familles les
plus aisées les diviser par deux ce
qu'on pensait que c'est une bonne piste
la piste de nos cieux bapt qui consiste
à dire on divise par deux les ménages
les plus aisés
mais en fin de compte ils s'attaquent
aux classes pen est une très mauvaise
solution
une très mauvaise solution c'est très
socialiste on donne le sentiment de
demander des efforts mais en fin de
compte il s'en prend de plein fouet aux
classes moyennes parce que ce que
propose le rapporteur danger doit de
financement de la sécurité sociale sur
la partie famille monsieur bah
socialiste c'est de dire un couple dont
chacun des membres à 2200 euros par mois
à eux terminé on divise par deux les
allocations celui ci arrive concernerait
que 10 % des bénéficiaires des
allocations familiales 4000 euros par
mois c'est les super riches
c'est peut-être les super riches de
monsieur hollande à l'époque mais pour
moi j'ai toujours dis les choses très
clairement si on veut avoir un discours
de vérité
je pense dans les années qui viennent
que pour les français les plus riches
les plus fortunés les plus aisés je
pense que il ne faudra plus verser les
allocations familiales
mais pour moi c'est bien au dessus des
classes moyennes je veux combien
d'années prenons par exemple le barème
de l'impôt sur le revenu la tranche
marginale
on est riche à partir de combien on
pense à la question et moi je suis pas
socialiste moi je me parlaient français
dans des cases
moi je tiens juste un discours de vérité
le discours de vérité si on ne fera
croire à personne que dans les années
qui viennent on pourra continuer à
donner tout à tout le monde mais la
différence c'est que je pense qu'il faut
préserver les allocations familiales
pour les classes moyennes et aussi pour
les français les plus modestes
et pour ceux qui sont les plus fortunés
il faut garder ce principe
d'universalité la politique familiale en
leur donnant toujours en leur
garantissant toujours l'accès par
exemple aux places en crèche
mais la méthode qui consiste à dire pour
le gouvernement fait officialisé mais
alors ça se désole attendait ses ballons
d'essai sur un ballon d'essai michael
ray contre ils ont quand même évoqué
l'idée la fiscalisation sais je donne
d'une main je reprend de l'autre c'est
bien socialiste à auterive et on la
retient quand même à ça veut priver les
très hauts revenus des allocations
familiales mais vous vous donnez pas de
chiffres encore je suis pas rapporteur
général du budget social et je suis pas
faire un projet de loi de financement
moi je dis les choses clairement pour
les plus hauts revenus je suis persuadé
que même préfère qu'on leur donne -
plutôt que de leur prendre toujours plus
comme le fait le gouvernement
aujourd'hui avec les impôts les
cotisations et les taxes alors on a
l'impression que l'ump ne fais plus de
quartier j'ai passé mettant tous les
ministres sont ciblées y compris manuel
valls qui était bombardé lors des
questions d'actualité et parce que je
pense que manuel valls est l'un des plus
mauvais ministre de l'intérieur qui soir
des coups de menton des grands discours
ou quand il nous dit régulièrement que
c'est inacceptable ça ne fait pas une
politique
manuel valls c'est le ministre de
l'intérieur qui avec daniel vaillant à
l'époque à les plus mauvais résultats en
matière de lutte contre la délinquance
on avait compris que c'était votre
chouchou jusqu'à présent a plaisanté
chouchou plaisanté alors un ministre par
nature un ministre par nature c'est
quelqu'un qui est jugé sur ses résultats
mais s'il y a un ministre qui plus que
les autres et jugé sur ses résultats
c'est le ministre de l'intérieur et
quand vous prenez notamment au premier
semestre 2012 c'était encore nicolas
sarkozy il y a eu 68 mille victimes de
délinquance en moins deuxième semestre
françois hollande manuel valls 45 mille
victimes de délinquance en plus voilà la
réalité et en définitive monsieur valls
aujourd'hui fait des discours très très
autoritaire mais où se plaît aussi
mais les français attendaient
n'attendent plus des discours d'attendre
des résultats et les résultats de manuel
valls en matière de délinquance ond très
mauvais et en définitive il se consacre
pas à 100% à la politique de lutte
contre l'insécurité de lutte contre la
délinquance contrer la crise n'est que
l'effectif donc elle a écouté c'est lui
qui est chargé des basses manoeuvres
pour protéger la gauche de la colère
électorale la réforme des modes de
scrutin
la réforme du mode de scrutin cantonal
la réforme du mode de scrutin sénatorial
le report du calendrier électoral pour
les régionales tout ça c'est parce
qu'ils ont conscience qu'aujourd'hui
français sont très en colère et que le
rôle aussi le monsieur valls c'est de
protéger le présent des républiques de
la colère électorale ce n'est pas ma
conception du rôle d'un ministre de
l'intérieur vous lui attribuez
aujourd'hui pour obtenir un rôle
politique plus qu'opérationnel en
matière de sécurité on voit bien le
temps qu'il a passé au parlement les
textes qui sont présentés qui ont été
discuté au sénat
monsieur valls occupe aller
d'électoralisme alors qu'il devrait
s'occuper à 100% de la lutte contre la
délinquance et en plus il faut bien voir
ce qui est en train d'arriver
la politique pénale que propose madame
taubira symbole de laxisme par
excellence je suis désolé tout ça nous
amène à de très mauvais résultats en
matière de délinquance et français
veulent être protégé ce n'est pas ce que
fait manuel valls aujourd'hui on se dit
que pour vous christiane taubira est
sans doute une cible quand même plus
facile parce qu'effectivement il
supprime et peuvent prendre plancher
supprimer les jurés populaires en
correctionnelle détricote certaines de
vos efforts
le problème n'est pas tricoter au
détricoter le problème c'est de garantir
la sécurité des français
ça passe bien évidemment par la
prévention ça passe par l'interpellation
ça passe aussi par une chaîne de
sécurité et notamment qui repose sur
l'action de la justice une action rapide
et une action ferme et le problème c'est
que ce sont des idéologues en permanence
parce que sarkozy la fin il faut défaire
mais les peines plancher
désolé c'est ce qui a permis d'éviter
que l'impunité ne soit érigée en règle
absolue je cherche quand même des points
communs entre vous et manuel valls et
xavier bertrand je me dis que peut-être
vaut également vous regrettez la mise en
cause de la laïcité ce sont les mots du
ministre de l'intérieur par la cour de
cassation qui est donc annulé le
licenciement de cette employée voilée de
la fameuse crèche baby loup est sur la
même ligne
écoutez j'ai toujours défendu le
principe de laïcité notamment dans cette
affaire de cette crèche baby loup dans
les yvelines
c'est ici mais ça se passe mes souvenirs
sont exacts m la question qui se pose
c'est la laïcité dans une crèche privée
qui assume pour moi une mission de
service public je l'avais dit dans mes
fonctions précédentes à l'assemblée
nationale je n'ai pas varié
la coordination science vient de rendre
une décision normalement n'a pas la
commenter et bien je commente alors
voilà comme cette décision aujourd'hui
porte un coup à la laïcité et je le dis
il nous faut très rapidement engagé
toute une étude pour savoir quelles sont
les personnes privées qui à notre sens
assumé mission de service public et
garantir la laïcité à l'intérieur
l'employé georges par exemple parce que
c'est 120 exemple type de service public
l'accueil des enfants et la laïcité doit
être garanti là et s'il faut passer par
une nouvelle loi
là je pense qu'il faudra que les
parlementaires ou le gouvernement
déposera il faut garantir la laïcité
partout sur notre territoire et à chaque
instant si une décision de justice
semblent remettre en cause cette laïcité
alors là il faut que le législateur
intervienne et là en la cité n'est pas
négociable et la laïcité ne peut pas
reculer à quelques endroits que ce soit
hélas en la matière vous diriez que
manuel valls a eu raison de sortir de
ses fonctions nous mettons de ce
problème ne venait je suis quand même
faire je suis en a je suis pas maître
d'école distribue pas mais l'alternance
ou des mauvais points on l'avait accablé
quand même tout à l'heure là il espère
des amis lui les dérogations détention
justice dont la france j'ai fait la même
chose on est quand même si les excuser
moi sur la position que j'avais aussi
quand j'étais ministre du travail sur
ces questions là alors j'aimerais qu'on
parle d'un autre ministre jérôme cahuzac
puisque d'après donc les dernières
informations de la justice sa voix sur
le fameux enregistrements
en temps quelqu'un évoqué un compte en
suisse est bien la sienne
selon l' enquête de la police comment
est-ce que vous réagissez quel est selon
vous aujourd'hui la position du ministre
du budget dans le gouvernement
je vais fait de commentaire sur ce sujet
je veux pas commencer à en faire
maintenant c'est à lui de s'exprimer
c'est à la justice de parler et je
voudrais juste vous dire une chose
qu'est-ce que ça tranche avec l'action
des socialistes vis-à-vis notamment de
mon ami eric woerth à l'époque
enfin ça vous l'avais déjà dit au début
de la faire là on a des éléments
nouveaux d'information il ya même une
information judiciaire qui est ouverte
pour blanchiment de fraude fiscale ça
vous entraîne pas un commentaire
supplémentaire d'allégeance en fallait
j'ai eu des cas à la justice de parler
monsieur cahuzac de parler point c'est
tout vient alors la législative
partielle de dimanche prochain dans
l'oise opposera donc l'ump au front
national
la candidate socialiste a été éliminée
dès le premier tour est ce que vous
imaginez une projection nationale de ce
scrutin c'est à dire un nouveau 21 avril
est surtout en train de se passer dans
l'oise on sent monter dans tout le pays
c'est une vraie colère des français
notamment de celles et ceux qui ont voté
pour françois hollande savait ce qu'ils
disent aujourd'hui françois hollande
il s'est bien foutu de nous parce
qu'anna qui ont sincèrement cru à ses
promesses qui ont cru que s'il y avait
le changement si nicolas sarkozy était
parti tout s'arrangerait comme l'avait
promis françois l'antre vous avez à la
fois des français qui sont très très
inquiets vous avez des français qui sont
très très en colère et ceux là font
payer aux socialistes
très clairement le matraquage fiscal
quant à l'époque il avait été dit parce
que je pense que françois hollande est
un spécialiste en mensonge
il a menti pendant toute la campagne et
il continue à le faire quand il avait
dit vous inquiétez pas il ya que les
très riches qui paieront et les
retraités aujourd'hui qu'ils paient une
cotisation de 0 3 0 6% l'an prochain qui
risquent de voir leur retraite progressé
moins vite que l'inflation à l'avenir
c'est leur souhait quand vous avez les
ouvriers qui faisait des heures
supplémentaires qui ont perdu le
bénéfice heures supplémentaires c'était
pas dit par françois hollande à l'époque
il a menti
maintenant bien sûr et vous savez les
français aujourd'hui juge encore une
fois sur les résultats on leur avait
promis tout irait mieux
et quasiment 10 mois après la france va
beaucoup
mal quand même une explication seulement
la crise dimanche prochain le parti
socialiste a appelé à voter contre le
front national dans l'oise vous l'avez
meute ex-allié bertrand comment est ce
que vous a apprécié cette attitude
républicaine je suis pas commentateurs
politiques
je suis moi alors amateurs ce que vous
seriez prêt un geste de 6000 dix fois on
nous a posé la question revient
aujourd'hui on y aurait ou non la
question de manière sûre c'est quoi
c'est qu'elle est le cas de figure la
semaine prochaine c'est mon cell front
national je serai dans l'oise votre
ennemi celle où allez-vous demander tout
simplement en plus directement si vous
êtes en accord avec la position de jean
françois copé qui dit ni ni ni ps ni
front national mettant déjà question
peut-être pas toujours été leur position
a toujours été ma position c'est à dire
en ce qui me concerne puisque vous venez
dire ouï je les dis à l'époque il y
avait des cantonales dans le
pas-de-calais et moi-même regardez moi
bien je t'ai victime d'une fatwa de
madame le pen aux élections législatives
a évoulé ma mort politique
eh bien je suis toujours là vous avez
évoqué la réforme des retraites il ya un
instant avec une cotisation
supplémentaire
vous prenez d'ores et déjà le passage à
la retraite à 62 ans pour tenter de
résorber les de douzy du taux plus tôt
que prévu c'est le truc en venant en
2017 je propose 2015 2015 de façon à
dire il faut travailler plus longtemps
d'accord mais en contrepartie ne touchez
pas aux retraités actuels vaccarès que
vous craignez la généralisation de la
désindexation des pensions comme ça va
se passer
en partie pour les retraites
complémentaires est ce qu'on croise une
piste sérieuse gouvernement est seul en
tête
jérôme cahuzac s'était exprimé les
autres ministres n'ose pas embrayé le
pas mais ils veulent aujourd'hui que les
pensions de retraite augmente moins vite
que l'inflation
et j'aurais juste vous porter un
témoignage voilà quelques semaines dans
une de mes permanences dans une commune
rurale à monsieur vient me voir il me
dit je suis retraitée de la fonction
publique quand je fais le plein de ma
cuve de fioul
ces 200 euros de plus ma mutuelle 14
euros de plus par mois
tout augmente si ma retraite elle
augmente plus je fais comment moi
voilà pourquoi
il faut absolument préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des retraités parce que d'une
part ça les fragiliserait et n'oublions
pas eu non plus il va un accord entre
partenaires sociaux y sont prêts à cette
fin il est ce que disent les gens aussi
cet horizon pas 13h07 hosties encore le
privé parce que le public les retraités
du public
eux ne sont pas concernés n'y a pas de
complémentaire et ce que je propose moi
également pour la réforme des retraites
où il faudra du courage c'est de dire
qu'il faudra en passer par un système
par points ou chacun en fonction de ses
cotisations pendant toute sa carrière se
voit attribuer des points mais c'est un
gros avantage public privé à 100% la
même chose journalistes parlementaires
le même régime de retraite public privé
le même régime de retraite plus question
des six derniers mois par rapport aux 25
meilleures années
exactement le même principe parce que
les français aujourd'hui son préféré
former une condition tout le monde est
logé à la même enseigne car alors il n'y
a pas que les élections partielles il ya
les sondages qui sont en berne pour
l'exécutif la dégringolade se poursuit
pour le chef de l'état pour le premier
ministre mais les ténors de l'opposition
en profite il la réponse nous est
apportée par sophie normand avant
d'accueillir à suzette bloch de l'
agence france-presse
jamais la cote de popularité d'un
président de la république n'est tombé
aussi bas ont seulement 10 mois de
pouvoir
selon le dernier baromètre ipsos
françois hollande ne récolte plus que 31
% d'opinions favorables
une tendance confirmée par tous les
instituts de sondages nicolas sarkozy en
son temps n'avait pas atteint un tel
plancher avant avril 2011 soit quatre
ans après son élection
un mécontentement à l'égard de
l'exécutif qui ne profitent pas pour
autant à l'opposition quand on regarde
un peu les résultats de ce baromètre on
s'aperçoit que les principaux leaders de
l'ump de la droite
eux aussi sont dégringolade en
dégringolade parce que finalement il ya
une défiance généralisée vis-à-vis du
personnel politique
et puis en dégringolade aussi auprès des
sympathisants ump qui finalement leur
prof aujourd'hui de ne pas faire
vraiment leur travail d'opposant ne pas
être audible et de ne pas proposer de
solution alternative crédible des
sondages en chute pour l'ensemble de la
classe politique même si le top 10 des
leaders les plus appréciés comporte six
personnalités de droite là
ternes ans ne crée plus d'espoir selon
ipsos ainsi le possible retour annoncé
de nicolas sarkozy il ya quelques
semaines n'a pas suscité l'enthousiasmé
chez les français les français n'ont pas
oublié qu'on était que l'ump était
encore au pouvoir il ya neuf mois
sa puce la crise l'ump de l'hiver ça
fait beaucoup pour un parti politique
ump en plein déni balaie d'un revers de
la main ces commentaires et préfère
revenir sur le premier tour des
législatives partielles dans la 2e
circonscription de l'oise dimanche
dernier partout la gauche est effondré
et la droite progresse dimanche dernier
encore jean françois mancel gagne 7
points par rapport à il ya dix mois
alors que le ps en perd 10 la droite
progresse à chaque élection partielle
on gagne les élections et la gauche ces
fonds si les législatives partielles ne
permettent pas de tirer de conclusion au
plan national les municipales de l'an
prochain seront un premier vrai test
pour la droite
vos questions et réactions
bien sûr ces sondages alors les leaders
de l'opposition ne profite pas des
déboires de la gauche dans les sondages
ça ne vous décourage pas ça montre
surtout une chose c'est que la situation
est tellement grave que dans
l'opposition aussi nous avons une
responsabilité particulière voilà
pourquoi s'opposer ne suffit pas
s'opposer ne suffit pas il nous faut
aussi proposer dire ce que nous ferions
à la place du gouvernement ce que je
fais notamment sur la question des
retraites ce que je fais dans le dossier
baby loup il s'agit pas pour nous de
dire à chaque fois ce qui ne va pas il
faut aussi dire ce que nous ferions
alors justement l'ump s'apprête à
défendre sa motion de censure contre le
gouvernement est ce que c'est le bon
moment à votre avis oui pourquoi pas ce
qu'il faut dire dès maintenant aux
gouvernements que depuis neuf mois
toutes ces décisions ont aggravé la
situation actuelle et qu'il faut changer
de politique économique quelle est la
première des priorités pour les français
l'emploi l'emploi l'emploi garder son
emploi que cet emploi permettent de
faire vivre sa famille et que ses
enfants aient un emploi or aujourd'hui
le chômage augmente en permanence et des
mesures s'en prennent aux mêmes
deux structures unia bertrand lequel
réformes de structure si vite je vais
vous dire d'investissement soyons
sérieux alors pourquoi le chômage depuis
neuf mois continue à augmenter sans
cesse sans limite où le président de la
république nous avons des tours du salon
de las il n'y aura pas de renversement
de tendance comme il l'avait promis il a
encore menti
la question de la crise expliquez-moi
pourquoi dans d'autres pays on réussit
mieux qu'en france il ya plusieurs
sujets des sujets conjoncturel mais on
n'est pas seulement pays bas les emplois
d'avenir en france ça ne marche pas nous
l'avions dit pourtant je n'ai pas voté
contre je n'ai pas voulu faire
l'opposant bête et méchant qui votent
non à tout quand quelque chose peut
aller dans le bon sens j'étais prêt à
donner sa chance chose que les contrats
aidés mais justement vous avez raison ça
prendra au galetas temps excusez moi
excusez moi j'aurais vous expliquer ça
prend la place des contrats aidés
ça fait pas reculer le chômage les
contrats de génération
j'ai peur que ça tue ou que
s'affaiblissent l'apprentissage ça
n'apporte pas de solutions plus vous
voulez une proposition concrète tout
chômeur aujourd'hui dans notre pays est
indemnisé à hauteur d'un peu plus de
14000 euros par an est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que ça vaudrait la peine pour
tout chef d'entreprise notamment un
artisan les très petites entreprises les
pme qui recruterait notamment un chômeur
de pouvoir lui dire vous ne paierez pas
de charge pendant un an ou deux ça c'est
simple c'est clair ça permet même de
faire des économies et surtout de
ramener vers l'emploi
cette mesure là c'est une mesure de bon
sens je crois au bon sens et vous avez
en plus docile autre sujet la soirée
nationale sur l'ancien agent sur
l'emploi justement vous voterez sans
doute cet accord sur l'emploi
si le texte qui sort de l'assemblée est
conforme et fidèle à l'accord national
interprofessionnel je voterai et voulez
que je vous dise ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale est
déjà en retrait par rapport à cet accord
national interprofessionnel notamment
sur la question du temps partiel
notamment sur la conciliation en matière
prud'homale discret
moi en catimini hypocritement
hypocritement le gouvernement est déjà
en train de modifier cet accord je suis
prêt dans sa chance depuis le
gouvernement déjà le texte qui arrive
n'est pas en tous points conforme à
l'accord national interprofessionnel ça
on le verra à la sortie de l'assemblée
nationale pour l'insertion
vous allez vous allez aussi travaillé en
commission pour vous proposer des
amendements je suppose donc sur cet
accord le nouveau leader de la cgt
thierry le paon
il voit un marqueur négatif la cgt reste
le syndicat dunant vous avez pas des
regrets
et quel titre des regrets je cours pas
la question
vous l'avez pratiqué la cgt la cgt
sincèrement au niveau national on s'est
aperçu que monsieur thibault toutes ces
années pour quelles évolutions de la cgt
moi ce que j'attends c'est lié à la
modernisation aujourd'hui monsieur le
mot est lâché quand même dans la bouche
de monsieur le banc hélas non mais vous
savez les discours cc c'est gentil mais
c'est le résultat qui compte
monsieur le plan veut donner un exemple
de la modernisation qu'il dise à la cgt
de presstalis qui est en train de faire
mettre un genou à terre à la presse
française d'arrêter de dire tout
simplement que la vocation de la cgt
presstalis qui est de dire à un journal
nous vous ferons disparaître si vous
voulez continuer la modernisation de la
presse de dire à la cgt de presstalis
mme stop c'est terminé nous ne pouvons
pas avoir aujourd'hui la cgt qui prend
en otage la presse française quotidienne
et hebdomadaire tout simplement pour
mettre tout le monde au pas alors bien
sûr la motion de censure mais vous avez
été associé à cette démarche
j'essaie démissionne j'ai signé cette
motion de censure associés maintenant
sans se faire vous voulez me faire dire
que si il ya eu peut-être davantage de
concertation en amont certains on
n'aurait pas tirer prétexte mais en tout
cas je le dis moi c'est le bon moment
pour dire ses racines belles chansons de
jean françois copé de montrer qu'il est
une chef de l'opposition mais écoutez la
belle affaire le vrai sujet c'est nous
disons non au gouvernement pour sa
politique économique et que pour le dire
il faut tous être unis et les deux
mamans aussi dans la vie publique faut
arrêter les querelles d'ego
la question des ondes
on doit être à juste justement mon nom
de choses inutiles sur bertrand en même
temps monsieur fillon part en russie
il a écrit le même jour au premier
ministre seront utiles et de la défense
et est ce que il n'ya pas une ou
deuxième thé celle de monsieur fillon
celle de monsieur copé ou est-ce que
vous vous situez dans tout ça
dans l'ump avec les militants qui sont
les véritables patrons notre famille
politique je n'ai pas participé moi
j'avais voté pour françois fillon
mais je n'ai pas participé à la
séparation des groupes parce qu'il me
semblait que c'était une folie mais ma
famille politique c'est l'ump et il
n'est pas question de l'affaiblir voilà
pourquoi demain oui j'ai modifié mon
emploi du temps pour être présents pour
écouter la motion de censure
et voilà pourquoi je voterai cette
censure du gouvernement quatre mois
après l'élection contestée de jean
françois copé est ce que c'est une
réconciliation de surface où il semble
comme vous semblez le faire dire que il
les plaies sont toujours avis c'est
parce que je vous ai dit j'ai des mois
qu'elle ait peur je vous ai dis moi qui
tu en moi je me situe du côté des
militants oui et pas des ambitions je
veux affirmer mais ma famille politique
c'est l'ump personne ne l'emportera si
l'ump n'est pas forte
est ce que je voudrais c'est qu'il y ait
au niveau national la même vitalité la
même unité que celle qui lie à sur le
terrain chez nos adhérents c'est à dire
par exemple il ya une hiérarchie en ce
moment petits déjeuners du mardi à 40
personnes
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est vivable
que c'est que lui même ne peut
fonctionner comme ça lui va dire quoi
quel petit déjeuner à 40 c'est beaucoup
c'est ce que je me dis voilà c'est
beaucoup parce que vous 419
responsabilité c'est beaucoup c'est vrai
mais ça n'empêche pas moi de jouer le
jeu de ma famille politique de jouer le
jeu des élections municipales d'aider
les candidats gelé encore fait dans le
département du nord la semaine dernière
je sais en permanence et une tournée
je fais cela depuis dix ans depuis dix
ans qu'elle depuis dix ans je crois aux
vertus du terrain moi je suis un
provincial qui croit profondément aux
vertus du terrain et qui sait aussi
pertinemment faire des discours c'est
bien écouter le message du terrain c'est
très bien les nouvelles élections de
l'ump en septembre je pensais que va y
avoir une réellement nouvelles élections
vous savez qu'il faudra poser la
question c'est pour ça qu'il faudra
poser la question aux adhérents j'avais
toujours tension oui seulement il faut
répondre c'est pas vous répondre savez
quand on me pose une question par oui ou
par non j'essaye de répondre par oui ou
par non sauf que quand c'est ça mérite
des précisions jeu juste les faire savez
ce que me disent les militants
aujourd'hui vous êtes pas mieux à faire
là leur procès de nouvelles élections
vous pensez pas que c'est mieux de vous
opposer au socialiste plutôt que de vous
opposer entre vous et puis déjà qu'on a
failli voir disparaître l'ump en
novembre dernier
si on a à nouveau une guerre est ce que
vous croyez sincèrement que cette fois
ci on en sortir alors moi ce que je
propose est très simple à l'occasion de
la réforme des statuts il faudra
demander aux militants s'ils veulent
voter oui ou non quand j'interroge
aujourd'hui je ne sens pas un
enthousiasme débordant pour revenir mais
le vrai patron de l'ump c'est le
militant moi ce que je propose je crois
que je suis le premier où seuls à
proposer
c'est que ce sont les militants qui
décideront par un vote si on doit
revoter et si oui un vote sur leur vote
sur à l'occasion notamment de la
validation de la réforme des statuts
d'accord donc mais vous donc vous n'êtes
pas non plus fortement favorable nouveau
s'entraîner tous alignés sur la veille
je m'alignais pas je propose qu'on prend
c'est moi qui initie cette démarche
accord mais qu'est ce que vous attendez
néanmoins de jean marc ayrault lors du
débat de censure de jean marc ayrault et
qu'il fallait espérer qu'il fasse preuve
de lucidité et de courage mais j'en
demande peut-être beaucoup parce que la
marre de ce gouvernement n'est vraiment
pas le courage
nous sommes à un moment donné où la
crise européenne est loin d'être passée
où les difficultés françaises sont
rendus plus importante à cause des choix
économiques quand vous augmenter la
pression fiscale de 33 milliards d'euros
depuis le début du quinquennat de
françois hollande
quand vous refuser d'engager les
réformes de fond la question du du
marché du travail la question des
retraites
question de la politique familiale mais
pas avec des sortes de demi mesure il
faut pas s'étonner que notre pays
justement ne résiste pas mieux à la
crise quand il n'y a pas de vraie
politique de l'emploi
on a envie de leur dire mais réveillez
vous n'attendez pas la fin de l'année
n'attendez pas de voir le chômage
progresser et quand en même temps vous
avez des mesures de clientélisme sans
pareil je dénonce le clientélisme de ce
gouvernement
quand on supprime le jour de carence
pour les fonctionnaires c'est du
clientélisme pour s'attirer les faveurs
de certains fonctionnaires
quand on fait voter une loi d'amnistié
social pour dire aux casseurs qui ont
cassé dans les entreprises eurent
amnistie pour vous c'est un vrai
scandale
je vous ai entendu demander la fin des
cures d'austérité en europe
vous avez dit taillé à la serpe dans
tous les budgets n'a pas de sens et vous
avez également figés madame merkel sa
politique au service des seuls intérêts
de l'allemagne
aujourd'hui vous nous parlez donc les
allocations familiales à long terme des
plus aisés devraient tous être supprimés
au même moment jean luc mélenchon sur
une ou deux plateaux de télévision
disait la même chose
jaliya sur moi c'est que sur la forme et
il semblait leveaux coûteux moi j'veux
pas de questions droits d'auteur du
livre mes convictions je suis
profondément européen 66 millions de
français dans le concert international
nous ne pouvons pas réussir seuls mais
je suis exigeant avec l'europe jeudi
notamment aujourd'hui que le traité de
libre échange entre l'union européenne
et les etats unis tel qu'il se présente
est un danger pour les intérêts
européens
et français je demande au gouvernement
d'utiliser la minorité de blocage pour
renégocier le mandat du commissaire
européen
ce que propose en définitive monsieur
obama c'est une sorte d'autant
économiques dans lesquelles nous ne
serions même pas dans le commandement
intégré
et quand monsieur obama dit que c'est un
très bon traité pour les pour les angles
sur les souches ans quand les ouvriers
pour les ouvriers américains
moi je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit une
très bonne nouvelle pour les ouvriers
européens
ou alors si on a un accord de libre
échange comme celui ci alors on dit aux
américains
soit vous renoncez à l' american pie hat
leur préférence nationale à eux ou alors
nous nous mettons en place avant
l'european by acte pas très français
mais c'est le terme exact pour dire de
la réciproque est il faut arrêter d'être
naïf le gouvernement de monsieur
hollande en catimini donne son feu vert
à cet accord qui est un danger pour
l'économie européenne et française
le gouvernement de monsieur hollande en
catimini or ouvre un chapitre de
négociations pour l'adhésion à la
turquie le gouvernement monsieur
hollande en catimini donne le feu vert à
la réouverture du dossier de la
directive bolkenstein il est passé où
monsieur montebourg avec sa
démondialisation il est passé où le
juste échange vous en acier hollande
elles sont passées où l'art et mélenchon
montebourg à l'afrique madame o qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de l'accord pour
sauver financièrement chypre et
notamment des contreparties et qu'on
était envisagée avec une taxation de
tous les dépôts bancaires
il ya une faute la part des ministres
des finances
une double faute la première fonderie
zone euro c'est d'avoir c'est de ne pas
avoir dit que le modèle de chypre
n'était pas un modèle transposable aux
autres pays parce qu'il ya un système
bancaire un système financier très
particulier la deuxième la deuxième
faute
la deuxième faute c'est également de ne
pas avoir dit au début que les petits
épargnants que les petits déposants eux
ne contribuerait pas en revanche qu'il
ya dans ce système c'est qu'à la
différence de la grèce il y a la
possibilité de faire payer non seulement
les plus riches mais surtout les
déposants étrangers les russes mais
aussi des anglais qui eux se font accès
alors qu'en grèce rappelez-vous l'une
des injustices a été que les très riches
armateurs avait pu déplacer leur argent
et n'était pas taxes
et que toutes avaient reposé sur le
peuple voilà la double faute des
ministres des finances et monsieur
moscovici se réveille tard 2017 je le
disais tout à l'heure c'est déjà dans
votre tête vous dites vous même à dix
fois par jour vous aviez bertrand mais
je pense à autre chose aussi ou celle
que vous pensez aussi à 2017 parce qu'on
vous promener dans les circonscriptions
dans les départements ce que vous faites
si souvent vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure perrine tarneaud va nous
rejoindre donc pour vous interroger son
vin sur votre stratégie notamment en vue
de cette primaire à droite stratégique
fabrice canet a tenté de comprendre leur
de xavier bertrand est elle venue
l'ancien ministre du travail on est
convaincu à raison d'un ou deux
déplacements par semaine
il tente de s'imposer comme un candidat
sérieux à la primaire de 2016
son handicap peut-être un certain
isolement au sein de l'ump
existe-t-il un isolement je n'en suis
pas sûr
puisqu'il avait réussi à rallier sur son
nom les signatures nécessaires pour une
éventuelle candidature à la présidence
de l'ump
à l'automne dernier mais s'il y avait
six allmand je vous demanderais très
simplement de regarder autour de vous ce
qui s'est passé au parti socialiste
françois hollande n'était plus premier
secrétaire il n'avait pas l'appareil
pour lui il a battu martine aubry à
l'image du centriste dominique paillé
xavier bertrand veut rassembler au delà
de l'ump
les statuts de son association de
soutien lancée en janvier pose
clairement cette ambition définir et
promouvoir une nouvelle offre politique
dans l'esprit d'un rassemblement le plus
large au sein de l'ump sa candidature
est prise très au sérieux en particulier
par les proches de françois fillon je
vois pas ce qui aujourd'hui est
handicapant pour cybertron
les dents se situe dans une ligne
d'action qui incontestable on peut lui
permettre d'arriver il faut qu'ils
fassent les efforts nécessaires pour le
faire il engage un compact et non un
combat de trois ans et xavier bertrand
s'est lancée tôt dans la course à
l'investiture avec tous les risques que
cela comporte de pas se battre en sur
régime
voilà ça c'est c'est parce que ça va
demander tellement de travail qu' on
peut on peut arriver à des situations de
surrégime dessus parce que j'appelle ce
que j'ai commis dans une autre vie de
surentraînement
c'est là on se blesse pour l'instant
c'est surtout l'ump qui est blessé et
xavier bertrand d'en profiter
dans cette course de fond il a choisi de
partir le premier s'il veut convaincre
il lui faudra maintenant tenir cette
stratégie sur la longue
voilà attention donc on surentraînement
claquage conseils sportifs
il sait de quoi il parle donc la course
de fond et la route va être longue
jusqu'en jusqu'au prévert de 2016 puis
2017 parce qu'il frappe
vous allez vers trans et votre
détermination rien ne vous détournera de
cet objectif
j'ai indiqué c'est clair comment comment
vous avez pris cette décision de sauter
finalement la case primaire présidence
de l'ump parlé directement jusqu'à 2017
je ne voulais pas prendre les adhérents
en otage je ne voulais pas leur mentir
en définitive dans les candidats que ce
soit fillon ou copé
chacun se disait qu'être président de
l'ump permettait de gagner le premier
tour de la primaire
pour être candidat à la présidentielle
il faut pas mélanger les genres
j'ai indiqué qu'à partir du moment où
mon ambition ma volonté
c'était d'être candidat à la
présidentielle et donc d'être candidat à
la primaire je ne voulais pas jouer sur
les deux tableaux je voulais pas mentir
aux adhérents et je me rends compte dans
toutes les réunions parce qu'on n'a pas
vu jusqu'au bout mais je fais pas des
grands discours
je parlais je donne la parole il ya des
échanges bien souvent me pose la
question pourquoi je ne suis pas allé à
la présidence de l'ump
et pourquoi je suis candidat à la
présidentielle et les militants l'ont
très bien compris il faut jamais leur
mentir ou revendiquer aujourd'hui votre
liberté et votre indépendance
oui je pense que c'est important la
fidélité à ma famille politique
je parcours régulièrement la france
depuis des années des années mais j'ai
besoin de le faire encore si vous voulez
bien comprendre à la fois ce qui marche
et pourquoi ça marche en france et ce
qui ne va pas et quelles sont les
solutions qu'on doit porter je pense
pour ma part qu'on ne gagnera pas 2017
ni avec les idées de 2012 ni avec les
idées 2007 la france est en train de
changer
donc ça fait 13 ans mon agent j'ai
choisi pour la conscription mais
lentement sûrement à votre rythme un peu
comme françois hollande l'a fait pour la
présidentielle 2012 j'ai pas le référent
j'ai pas de modèle moi j'ai avant tout
besoin de vraiment comprendre ce qui
dans notre pays a besoin d'être libéré
et ce qui a besoin d'être libéré c'est
l'esprit d'entreprise c'est l'initiative
je pense que le premier défi français
c'est l'emploi
je l'indiquais tout à l'heure et force
est de reconnaître savez j'étais
ministre du travail et de l'emploi
j'ai eu à affronter des crises
difficiles j'ai eu à annoncer des bonnes
nouvelles et bien souvent des mauvaises
nouvelles pendant la crise personne ne
doit faire la personne ne doit faire le
malin en la matière et je sais qu'on a
un problème français avec le chômage et
qu'il faut justement faire davantage
confiance aux entreprises aux
entrepreneurs baisser les charges
sociales alors baisser les charges
réglementaires et encourager l'emploi
sous toutes ses formes et je pense que
pour cela elle à la rencontre des chefs
d'entreprise
mais ça a du sens mais quand vous
démarrez les militants du ps des
questions examinées mais attend et
comment vous allez faire la différence
avec les autres avec les copains et
fillon comment vous vous ferez la
différence je pense être sur une ligne
politique et stratégie qui repose sur
trois axes que je suis le seul à porter
je veux une droite synonyme de justice
les choix que feront les réformes que
nous devrons mettre en oeuvre devront se
faire dans la justice les français vous
disent on est prêt à faire des efforts
mais pas toujours les mêmes qui payent
il faut qu'il y ait cette justice je ne
veux plus jamais être caricaturé comme
on l'a été à tort pendant cinq ans comme
les amis les privilégiés un la justice
de de seynois qui va jusqu'au bout des
réformes qui a identifié les blocages
français les corps intermédiaires
parfois et qui sans négliger les corps
intermédiaires mais sur des sujets
essentiels la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi
réforme des institutions et en creux une
critique du bilan de nicolas sarkozy est
ministre nicolas sarkozy pendant cinq
ans alors dans ces cas là je m'auto
critique je dois je regrette
foncièrement qu'on n'ait pas pu mettre
en place le contrat unique de travail et
qu'aujourd'hui on est tous débat pour
savoir s'il faut taxer les contrats
courent on aurait mis en place ce
contrat unique de travail mais quand on
l'a proposé mais défend textes ou
interviews d'artistes aussi la réforme
jusqu'au bout et le troisième c'est le
discours sur l'europe
je pense que nous devons absolument
réconcilier les français avec l'europe
et ça passe par l'idée qu'il faut être
euro exigent pas heureux eurosceptiques
pas fédéraliste et des notions du siècle
dernier mais il faut absolument être
très exigeant avec l'europe en matière
de convergence fiscale regarder les
buralistes vont manifester demain mais à
chaque fois vous augmenter les prix du
tabac
cette buraliste belge ou espagnole qui
se frottent les mains
parce que dit la cour des comptes a qu'à
chaque fois que l'encadrement français
ce qu'il est avec ses sur l'inflation
c'est mehdi sur lui parce qu'il ya aussi
des contrats qui ont été passées pour
maintenir le métier de buraliste
mais le rôle de l'europe notamment c'est
de pouvoir mettre en place un prix du
tabac qui soit pas si différent entre
deux pays
là au moins on n'aura pas les problèmes
de contrebande hélas et de vous vous
avez bertrand personnellement qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de mettre en avant
dans cette campagne de fond peut-être
une dimension de vraie proximité et de
courage vous savez moi je il n'était pas
inscrit à 8 ou 10 ans qu'un jour je
voudrais être candidat à la présidence
de la république
mais on fut les candidats à la
présidentielle disent que c'est quelque
chose qui lui porte depuis longtemps et
bien pas mère m'a dans ma chambre
j'avais pas les posters de prison et les
posters de joueurs de foot
excusez moi j'ai pas devenu joueur de
foot ça se voit mais toujours est il que
c'est pendant le dernier quinquennat
j'ai vu le courage de nicolas sarkozy et
j'ai vu que le courage en politique
n'était pas la vertu la plus répandue et
à partir du moment où il l'a dit qu'il
tournerait la page s'il n'était pas
réélu après son discours de la mutualité
là j'ai envie de porter mes convictions
et je suis vraiment persuadé qu'il faut
aussi réconcilier les français que la
politique
voilà pourquoi je pousse des
propositions qui sont que nos classes je
le sais
quand je dit l'un des poisons français
c'est la réélection pour un président de
la république qu'une fois qu'ils étaient
lus il pense forcément à sa réélection
je suis pour proposer par référendum un
septennat unique ou celui qui sera élu
mais français se diront peut-être que
celui ci fera vraiment le travail que
l'on attend de lui et si on est aussi
sur le recours au référendum j'y crois
beaucoup
si je veux parler de fusionner
départements et régions mais vraiment
fusionner un peu dans l'esprit de ski de
fond en alsace mais dans tous les
départements et régions de france il
faudra passer par référendum que jamais
la classe politique ne se fera hara kiri
autrement il faut faire appel au peuple
faux pas sont méfiés il faut faire
confiance aux pôles elle exhale et
bertrand de trois questions d'actualité
pour terminer d'abord au nom de la crise
est-ce qu'il faut sacrifier le budget de
la défense en france en certainement pas
ce qui se prépare aujourd'hui est une
catastrophe budgétaire sans pareil pour
la défense et je demande au président de
la république de ne pas écouter ce qui
se dit à bercy la défense n'est pas une
variable d'ajustement
mais ce qu'on a encore les moyens d'être
une grande puissance militaire j'en suis
intimement persuadé que le budget de la
défense ne progresse plus ou qu'on ne
répondent pas à la demande de l'otan qui
est de dire qu'il faut un budget
militaire de 2% justement vous ne pouvez
pas aller plus loin ou alors il faut
avoir le courage de dire que si les
décisions dont on parle aujourd'hui
deviennent réalité nous ne serons plus
capables dans les années qui viennent
d'envoyer quatre mille hommes
au mali comme on l'a fait pour s'opposer
aux troupes terroristes et djihadistes
vous pourriez avoir des forces spéciales
sur le terrain mais plus la projection
de quatre mille hommes si vous avez
cette catastrophe budgétaire en termes
de défense
vous pouvez faire une croix sur une
grande partie des quatre mille pme qui
sont des industriels de l'armement et
qui sont aujourd'hui des emplois dans
notre pays et le pire c'est que si les
mauvaises décisions sont prises
aujourd'hui jamais nous nous
rattraperons ce retard si vous n'avez
pas des programmes militaires
vous avez notamment des hélicoptères qui
ne pourront plus être vendus à
l'étranger dans les mêmes conditions
la défense c'est à la fois notre
influence et notre rayonnement c'est
aussi de l'emploi
on n'a pas le droit de sacrifier la
défense et là je le dis sur un sujet
comme celui ci
s'il ya des décisions qui sont sérieux
seul il peut y avoir unité nationale
mais certainement pas s'il y a ces
sacrifices qui sont demandés à la
défense à la vague ça n'aurait pas de
sens la défense est aussi une priorité
nationale
est-ce que ce les otages vous approuver
le changement de doctrine du
gouvernement c'est à dire de ne plus
payer de rançon je sais que c'est
difficile à entendre pour les familles
je sais que ça source d'inquiétude mais
oui je pense
je pense parce que si vous dites que
vous êtes prêts à payer une rançon
qu'est ce qui vous garantit qu'une
semaine après la libération
vous n'aurez pas de nouvelles prises de
tâches je sais que c'est très difficile
pour ceux qui qui peuvent écouter qui
ont les leurs pris en otage un très
grand respect et évidemment mais là ce
sont des sujets sur lesquels il faut
aussi tenir un discours de vérité même
si elle est difficile à entendre du
gouvernement actuel mais les jeux je
tiens je tiens aujourd'hui le même
raisonnement
même si en plus sur ces sujets là en
famille à on amplifie moins on en parle
j'ai bien conscience que pour les
familles en elle même entendre ce
discours là ça doit être difficile mais
je crois aussi que le discours s'adresse
à aller terroristes qui sont sans foi ni
loi qu'il faut aussi tenir ce discours
est un discours de vérité de fermeté
dernière question dans la sphère du
médiator l' agence du médicament est
mise en examen pour blessures
involontaires votre réaction d'anciens
ministres la santé c'est que cette
agence du médicament
l'ancien agent de sécurité du médicament
elle doit répondre aussi des actes de
certaines ses dirigeants l'époque le
rapport de l'igas avait été très clair
je ne suis pas étonné derrière qu'il y
ait des suites judiciaires
mais je voudrais dire qu'il ya la
question judiciaire il à la question de
l'indemnisation des victimes qu'il en
ait réglé et ça va trop lentement
le collège d'experts est en train de
faire un tri entre les malades ce n'est
pas convenable il y à un responsable
cette affaire ses laboratoires servier
ses laboratoires servier qui doit
indemniser et on ne doit pas avoir un
comité d'experts qui deviendrait une
machine à dire non dernière question la
plus parler du retour éventuel de
nicolas sarkozy
en libye est ce que vous imaginez
possible un jour son retour politique
s'il accepte comment on lui a fait la
proposition du thon la présidence du
fonds souverain du qatar
écoutez vous lisez tout vous regardez
tous les étés sap a été démentie par
l'entourage de nicolas sarkozy au patro
la promesse des crazy il me semble que
si écouter ses proches ont démenti
une chose est certaine il a dit lui
qu'il tournait la page de la politique
laissez le tranquille merci à vous et
xavier bertrand merci d'avoir été avec
mais cette semaine merci père est né la
semaine prochaine c'est françois bayrou
qui sera notre invité pour ce
rendez-vous de preuves par 3 a très vite